CARTER MORGAN:
Today, we're talking
about subsea cable,
startup, sustainability,
and monitoring your VMs.
I'm Carter Morgan, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
We're excited to announce
Apricot, a new subsea
cable that will connect
Singapore, Japan, Guam,
the Philippines,
Taiwan, and Indonesia.
It's expected to be ready
for service in 2024.
In total, we have investments
in 18 subsea cables
alongside our 27 Cloud regions
in 82 zones around the world.
Check out the blog for more
about the subsea cables
and connectivity.
Our first-ever Google
Cloud Startup Summit
will be taking place
on September 9, 2021.
Google Cloud is committed to
maximizing your potential,
and we know how critical
mentoring and support
can be on a startup journey.
We hope you will join us as
we bring together our startup
community, including startup
founders, CTOs, VCs, and Google
experts to provide
behind-the-scenes insights and
inspiring stories of innovation.
Check out the blog for a look at
the agenda and register today.
A recent
Google-commissioned study
illustrated the importance
of sustainability
for organizations'
IT departments,
while also revealing
that significant work is
needed before businesses meet
their sustainability goals.
The good news is that 90%
say that sustainability
is a priority for
their IT departments.
And as more organizations
consider the benefits
of digital transformation
and Cloud migration,
sustainability is a must-have
or major consideration when
evaluating Cloud providers.
Check out the blog to
learn about the obstacles
and pathways to progress and how
Google Cloud can be supportive.
We're happy to announce
the general availability
of an enhanced, in-context
set of UI-based tools
for Compute Engine users to
help make the troubleshooting
journey easier and
more intuitive.
From the Google
console, developers
can click into any VM
and access a rich set
of prebuilt visualizations
designed to give insights
into common scenarios and issues
associated with CPU, disk,
memory, networking,
and live processes.
With access to all of
this data in one location,
you can easily correlate between
signals over a given time
frame.
Check out the blog for more.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see the full list,
check out the link.
And if you have any
thoughts or ideas,
leave us a comment or tweet us.
And we'll see you in the Cloud.